we've had a little bit of a break from
notable heckling zuv trump
administration and right-wing officials
but i have for you today arguably the
most prominent one in a long time Ted
Cruz who ended up leaving his restaurant
date I guess with his wife yesterday
after protesters insisted with a we
believe survivors chant and it was
pretty great and it previously happened
to trump Secretary of Homeland Security
Kristen Nielsen it happened to Trump's
whacky policy advisers Stephen Miller
who was I think trying to have sushi
right let the guy have a salmon roll yes
there are Huckabee Sanders - Sarah
Huckabee Sanders at the Red Hen
something or other and I believe West
Virginia Virginia and now it is Ted Cruz
at DC restaurant Feola where you can get
a beautiful tasting menu for about a
hundred and fifty bucks per person they
will gladly pair it with their grand
wine pairing for an additional two
hundred and ten dollars per person
giving you a delightful evening for
three hundred and sixty bucks per person
at the dinner great restaurant try the
caviar if you get the chance but Ted
Cruz and his wife apparently not able to
check out what happened the video is
from Smash racism DC we're gonna play it
for you my two favorite moments of the
video and I want you to listen for both
of these because they're just great
little details in the midst of the we
believe survivors chant at one point
you're gonna hear Cruz in that
cartoonish voice of his say god bless ya
and then the top moment for me is when
one of the protesters says to Cruz that
his opponent Beto or Warrick is way
hotter than he is which is just
brilliant check out the video
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
how dare they
ted cruz ended up having to leave his
beautifully paired wine dinner to go to
a nearby 7-eleven and he had half a
dozen of those hot dogs that they have
rotating on the spinner machines all day
not a good night for Ted Cruz I've gone
back and forth on this okay or maybe not
back and forth I've been nuanced on this
saying I support protesting but not
violent protesting and I've wondered
about the sort of pragmatic
effectiveness of any particular protests
like this I am increasingly on the side
that we are going to need to make people
uncomfortable to achieve change every
time I say this I get angry emails from
from the audience some people even
cancel their memberships I am NOT saying
specifically that heckling Ted Cruz at a
restaurant is going to achieve any
change in the future of Brett
Cavanaugh's confirmation for example
right which is the topic of this protest
I believe survivors but what I am
Telling You is that if protesting was
limited only to the protests that those
in power are comfortable with nothing
would ever change right nothing would
ever change if you go to the people that
maintain the status quo and say mister
mister
Oleg Ark mister person in power whatever
people want change but we want your okay
for how they should protest and advocate
for that change give us the list of how
people should protest they say oh sure
write us letters to our congressional
office and then my aide will file it
and then you can hold the sign quietly
if you want but it's got to be smaller
than three feet by three feet and you
can do it in a free speech zone at least
200 feet away from where I'm going to be
speaking know by definition you have to
understand that protests and civil
disobedience and general strikes like I
talked about yesterday
they're not going to be liked by a lot
of people that's the nature of these
things so when people say you're
encouraging disrespectful behavior he's
a public servant but he's allowed to go
to dinner and you David are only saying
it because you disagree with Ted Cruz
and if people did it to bernie you'd be
mad wrong first of all go look at my
commentary from a month or two ago when
Alex Jones heckled Bernie Sanders at an
airport at no point that I say that's
simply going up and heckling him or
asking questions is the problem the
problem is that he's heckling thanked
him about things that make no sense and
I disagree with what change he's trying
to bring by heckling Bernie Sanders by
the way in that viral Alex Jones Bernie
video my friend ari Rabin offed was the
guy travelling with Bernie and I saw him
in New Orleans last month and I asked
him did Bernie really not know who Alex
Jones was or was he playing coy when he
said Ari who is this guy and Ari said no
no it's even better because Bernie
genuinely had no idea who he was
he said after the fact who was that guy
Alex Jones well Marco Rubio took the
same approach too after that Facebook
congressional testimony parted although
I I think Marco Rubio knows who Alex
Jones is just pretend he's not relevant
though but back to our primary topic I
might disagree with why you were
protesting but we have a broken
democracy here we have voter suppression
we have policy foreign by the rich it's
a straight up insulting thing to say to
suggest you can't protest non-violently
in these ways we are running out of ways
to effect change they are setting it up
so that you can't disturb the system
it's a shame but heckling politicians is
one of the fewer and fewer remaining
ways to get attention and to express
discontent and as I told you yesterday
you've got stagnant wages you've got
health care that's tied to jobs you've
got people commuting hours to their job
whose wages have not increased for 40
years in real terms we have a system
designed by those in power to prevent P
but from having the timer means to
protest in a serious and effective
manner civil disobedience general
strikes heckling politicians you can do
this stuff and I say good for you I
might argue with them Pat because I
might say well I don't agree with the
cause you're protesting for or I think
you're on the wrong side of an issue but
I'm not going to say this is
disrespectful and you can't do it
because we have increasingly fewer and
fewer ways to actually protest and of
course the best case scenario is Ted
Cruz getting voted out in November bait
overwork replacing him yeah but even
then Cruz is going to be a senator until
January and he's probably going to be
able to vote on that Cavanaugh
confirmation if you happen on whoever
else Trump picks no doubt so you have to
be able to do more you have to and if
you still disagree with me on this let
me know I'm ready and willing and I hope
people will call in during during live
calls on the Friday show and tell me if
you disagree and we can talk about it